coronavirus isn't the only invisible
enemy threatening Britain's way of life
disinformation about the disease some of
it allegedly spread by pro-russian media
is also causing concern the Armed Forces
Minister has started using his own
Twitter feed to dispel fake covert 19
news I think most of the instances are
people just getting the wrong end of the
stick there'll be a couple of things
where people have sort of seen videos of
tanks on the motorway and fort where
here's an opportunity to stir up some
trouble and then of course there is the
reality that there will be people who
are doing this very deliberately to sow
disinformation to erode trust in the UK
government and that's something that as
a government is an mo D we're very aware
of we need to try to tackle but the
priority is to tell people where they
can go to get information they can trust
the coronavirus has made headlines
around the world since it first appeared
in China last year yes sir
this Russian outlet suggests Britain had
a vaccine a year ago it also repeats
false rumors linking British scientists
to the sole three spy poisoning yeah an
accreta would give and this clip tries
to draw a link between covert 19 and the
opium wars between Britain and China
this new report published online
identifies more than 110 cases of what
it describes as Corona related
disinformation by pro-kremlin media
outlets this internal EU document goes
further accusing kremlin disinformation
of seeking to aggravate the public
health crisis in Western countries
Moscow denies the claims accusing the EU
of being the ones peddling the fake news
yet critics accuse Vladimir Putin of
exploiting moments of crisis supported
by Russian state media there's been a
pattern going on for years now of anti
Western and conspiratorial content going
around particularly in the Russian media
and particularly in the Russian language
and it looks like the main goal is
really to make the Russian government
look better by making everyone else look
worse the coronavirus crisis is a
breeding ground for fake news another
frontline in this unprecedented fight
Deborah Haines Sky News